[MUSIC]
Hello, welcome everyone to
the Stanford MBA Admissions Panel on
Your Journey From Stanford to Europe.
My name is Lisa Giannangeli, and
I'm a Director of MBA admissions,
as well as an alumna of the program.
And I'm joined today by some of my fellow
alumni who will share some of their
experiences, both at Stanford, and
now working and living in Europe.
You'll see a couple of polls on your
screen throughout today's presentation.
We'd really appreciate your input there.
And if at any point you have a question
that you would like to ask our
panelists later on, please feel
free to pop that in the Q&A box.
So just to understand a little bit about
what we will cover in today's event.
Really our aim is to allow you
an opportunity to engage with
our community and to learn a little bit
more about the Stanford GSB experience.
And then also some of the experiences
of our alumni who are now currently
living and working in Europe.
I'll give a super brief introduction
to our global community,
you'll have an opportunity
to meet our panelists.
I'll start us off with
some Q&A ,and then again,
we really want to hear your questions.
So at any point, feel free to type
your question in to that Q&A box.
If you see a question that someone else
has asked that you particularly like,
you can click on that thumbs up symbol and
that'll vote that question up to the top.
And we'll try to address as many
questions as we can in our 55
minutes together today.
So where will your journey take you?
Well, a Stanford MBA could
really take you almost anywhere.
It's interesting, as students
are arriving to Stanford, again,
they're coming from all around the world.
And we see a number of regional
clubs on campus that form.
And every year there's a robust group
that's in the Europe Club on campus.
Similarly, after you graduate,
this journey can take you again
almost anywhere you want to go.
We have approximately 60 regional
alumni clubs all around the world,
45 of which are outside
of the United States.
There are about 30,000
GSB alumni globally.
And a much, much broader Stanford
University network all around the world
that you can absolutely tap into at any
point personally or professionally.
But let's take an opportunity now
to meet some of our panelists.
So we have a wonderful group today of
alumni who are currently living and
working in Europe.
It'd be great if each of our alums could
just briefly introduce yourselves.
We'll go in the order that we
see here on the slides, and
Christina we'll start with you.
>> [COUGH] Sorry, yes, hi everyone.
My name is Cristina LaMarca,
I graduated in summer 18.
I currently live in London where I work
at Libor in a commercial function.
Prior to going to Stanford, I was at
McKinsey and Company focusing mostly on
food and beverage,
that's always been a passion of mine.
And in 2019,
I moved from New York to London.
So nice to meet you all.
>> Hi everybody,
my name is Stefan Hildebrandt.
I graduated in 16, as you can see there.
I'm originally from Germany, and
lived in the US for a combined 17 years.
So I was in the US before
the Stanford MBA, I worked in New York.
And I'd started a commercial bakery
business there that we then sold and
moved back to Germany right after the MBA.
>> And Sita I know is joining us, yes.
>> Yeah, hi guys,
nice to virtually meet all of you.
My name is Sita, I'm originally from
Austria, have been abroad for eight years.
Part of that was obviously my time
at the GSB and right after the GSB.
Took my then American boyfriend,
now husband, to London and
then now back to Austria.
Professionally, I was in telco before,
wanted to do something with
an impact on climate change.
Did a lot of energy classes,
renewable energy classes at the GSB,
and then went into sustainable mobility.
And I'm now working
with electric vehicles.
>> Hi all, here is Patricia.
I am an MBA 2012.
I'm an engineer,
education originally from Spain.
Before the MBA I worked in consulting,
also McKinsey, Madrid office.
And after the MBA I moved to Germany,
directly worked with
the European Central Bank since then for
the last eight years in
different functions.
Now taking care of distributing or
banknotes to all of those you who are in
Europe, and very happy to be here.
>> Hello, everyone,
great to virtually meet everyone.
My name is Maxim, and I graduated from
Stanford 15 years ago, a long time ago.
Prior to the university,
I worked in private equity as well as
corporate development in telecoms.
And after graduation,
I think I have taken three roles.
First of all, I was the CEO of
a printing press distribution company,
then I had the media
holding company in Russia.
And I think for the over seven years,
I'm one of the shareholders and
the founder of [INAUDIBLE} Group,
which is real estate marketplace.
Like classifieds and marketplace,
something like zillow.com or
Rightmove or Maybeletscall24 for
the European counterparts.
Great to answer questions today.
>> Great, thank you all.
So I'll start us off with some
questions for our panelists.
But again, we really also want
to hear from you, our attendees.
So any questions that you have for our
panelists, please feel free to put those
in the Q&A box and
we'll get to those in just a few minutes.
So this first question is really for
any of our panelists,
anyone who wants to chime in.
But why did you decide to pursue an MBA
and why specifically at Stanford?
>> So for me, it was very obvious.
I'm an engineer's education, and I landed
into consulting for random reasons.
So I always felt like I didn't really
have the background knowledge I needed.
So I was learning on the job the whole
time, which was fun and was interesting.
But I felt like I needed to
sort of build up my skills.
So an MBA was clear, why Stanford.
For me, Stanford is very special
in the sense that it allows
cross disciplinary training and education.
And for me this was very important.
So as an as an engineer who was working in
sort of business world, I always felt like
one can add value and innovate when
you're In the middle of two disciplines.
And I think Stanford does a great job at
allowing that also throughout the MBA
program.
Being on campus is one thing and
being able to take classes across
the street is even better.
So, for me, the decision was very clear
from the beginning because of that.
>> Maxim, did you want to talk about why
you decided to do an MBA and why Stanford?
>> Yeah,
I think it was a very interesting for
me because the reason I
decided to join Stanford and
the reason why I changed my career
afterwards are totally different.
So I applied and I got admitted to
Stanford with the idea of becoming
a partner in private equity and
venture capital fund.
And obviously Stanford is the ultimate
university for that I would say.
So actually, I think there were two
schools that were really important for
such a career, Stanford and
the other school.
And actually, it was clear choice for
me to go to Stanford on that.
Having said that,
over the course of two years,
I actually decided to change
my kind of profession.
I spent summer internship working for
a VC company in Silicon Valley and
decided that it's a great job,
I would love to do it maybe 20,
30 years after graduation, but
not just after the graduation.
So I decided that it's much more fun,
and I think it's much more natural for
me to manage people rather than
Excel sheets and PowerPoints.
So I decided that I would go for
any job which takes responsibility and
manage a lot of people.
That's what I need actually
at the end of the day.
>> The sixth question I'll
direct toward Stefan and Maxim,
but how have you connected with or
leveraged the alumni community in Europe,
either personally speaking or
professionally speaking?
>> Yeah, I can speak to that a little bit.
I decided to move to Germany
with my then pregnant wife,
American wife,
very unsure how that move would go for
the two of us, both personally and
professionally.
And in the second year, there's a big push
to kind of start connecting with alumni.
I think a really good starting
point is the alumni database that I
actually do use quite frequently.
And I just started searching for
people in Germany, for people in Munich
specifically, because we were going to
move to Munich at that point.
And I remember, and this is a true story,
I know it sounds made up, but
it really is a true story.
I reached out to a handful of people
in Munich, and then one of them,
well, everybody kind of
emailed back right away, but
one of them said, hey, that's amazing
that you're moving to Munich.
Would you be at all interested
in me hosting a dinner so
that you can get to know a whole
bunch alumni at the same time?
And I thought that I had no idea where
this was coming from, I didn't know him.
And he said, yeah, I'd be happy to do it.
So literally,
after four weeks of being in Germany,
there was a dinner at somebody's house.
I think there were 25 people there or
something, and
it was an amazing start for me, right,
not knowing a whole lot of people,
because I had never lived in Munich.
I grew up in Stuttgart, but
I was gone for so many years.
And it was an amazing introduction
into kind of like at Stanford.
It really is like a family in Munich,
right?
This is not New York or San Francisco,
where there's just hundreds of alumni.
There's clearly a more
limited amount of them.
But they were super open.
They helped right away.
I mean,
I've gotten investors through them,
a bunch of them invested in our business.
And I've nothing but
good things to say, right?
Again, it's a smaller network than
you will get from some of the other
programs in Europe, obviously,
just by the sheer size of the class and
the geographic location.
But the accessibility and the willingness
to help is very, very high.
>> Maxim, would you like to share your
experiences connecting with alumni?
>> I think I'll give three
examples of my personal story.
First is about not professional relevant,
like personal.
I totally echo Stefan's
point on the really close
community in European countries,
and more family style kind of feeling,
I would say.
Each of Stanford GSB graduates knows each
other quite well, and we get together with
the families, and we can go fishing
together, we can go and travel.
So it really feels like
similar culture and
similar values,
which are really important,
as well as everyone is so
kind of open to share what he or
she has with the rest of the community,
GSB community here in Moscow.
And I also like traveling around
the globe before Coronavirus came about.
And actually, it's really great
to send an email to any of
my classmates in any country in the world,
actually, and
get the best experience
within that country,
both from a professional and
from personal viewpoint.
And on the careerwise,
GSB alumni helped me a lot.
First, I got my first CEO
position through GSB network,
and definitely,
it is one of the greatest opportunities
that alumnis have got after graduation.
And obviously, it is due to the fact
that we all share the same experience,
but the idea that actually,
literally, within one day,
everyone answers your email because
you also graduate from GSB.
It's what I have experienced a lot.
And for example,
my current co-partners, ETSAN,
it's Internet real estate marketplace,
and they are GSBs as well.
So they were raised over $1
billion fund from JP Morgan,
European pension funds, etc.
But it was very easier for
us to close the deal, basically,
to bring investments to ETSAN when
we decided to raise new money,
because I mean, they think the same way.
They also kind of share the idea
of how to build business together.
And I think over
the course of seven years,
I truly feel that we are like-minded.
We share the same ideas, and
obviously, we have some arguments, but
we understand how to resolve
them in a professional manner.
And that's definitely
another really important
angle to Stanford community, thank you.
>> Sita,
I'm actually going to cold call you.
I've heard you talk in the past
about your Stanford GSB tribe.
Do you want to share
a little bit about that?
>> Yeah, happy to.
So this is a post graduation development.
Actually, Stefan and I are in the same
tribe, if I may share that much.
So we were a bunch of people who were
going to move away from California,
and more specifically, to Europe
towards the end of our time at the GSB.
We knew that we were going to go
directly to Europe, different countries.
And we really wanted to stay
connected to sort of the school,
to thinking, that sort of cultural aspect
that Maxim was just talking about.
And we just started a group of,
initially, I think we had three tribes,
sort of Latam, US, and
Europe, ten people each, and
we're still going strong five years later.
We're basically meeting up about
every quarter, used to be in person,
now, we've obviously switched
to virtual meetings.
And it's just a great way to spend
a good chunk of time together.
We usually do either a full weekend or
a longer workshop session where
we just kind of share personal or
professional Issues we're
struggling with are things
that we want our GSB colleagues input on
and really depending on what people need,
if they need coaching,
if they need support, whatever it is.
We try to help each other out and kind of
bring that GSB spirit into our lives and
it's been such an enriching experience,
I'm very, very thankful for it.
It takes a lot of, So
you have to really stick with it and
everybody really needs to get a little
value out of it, because everybody
obviously starting families and businesses
and has a lot of different priorities.
But people have really made it
a priority and that's been great.
>> Okay, thanks for sharing.
The next question I'll
direct to Patricia and Sita.
Can you talk a little bit more about how
you made that transition from the GSB to
Europe and sort of what sort of
things were most helpful?
Was it alumni connections or
did you do summer internship or
a global study trip in Europe, did you do
class projects with European companies?
Was it Career Management Center report?
How was your path and what did you find
most helpful in making that transition?
Maybe Patricia starting with you.
>> So from my side, I mean,
I have a little bit of a special career
in the sense that after Stanford,
I went to a public institution and
this was something that I wanted to do.
And it was very clear I wanted
to do already from the start.
So I had to figure
a little bit my way out.
It's I got a lot of support from
the Career Management Center.
We had a special person assigned to
international students back then I don't
know if it's still the case.
And she discussed them with us in terms of
what we wanted to do right these with me
what I wanted to do,
what is it exactly that I wanted?
I mean,
public institutions is very opened to me.
So was it in Europe, was it not?
What was it that was important for
me and really going to the core?
I also leveraged after understanding
what is it exactly that I want,
I leveraged a lot of the alumni
database as Stefan was mentioning.
So really looking through
the database looking for
people who had done similar things
like me, also in Europe, and
just reaching out getting
an answer immediately.
Having phone calls,
sort of half hour chat,
just understanding how they have done it,
what they liked, what they didn't like,
what worked well,
what didn't work so well.
And just learning from those experiences
and then starting my own sort of reach
out,, so
I reached out a lot within my two years.
I would say not only Europe
actually because this was not so
clear from the beginning.
So I did also explore other options North
America, for example, and also the US.
But I think a lot of the process is
really looking or seeing it for yourself.
So really talking to the companies talking
to the people going to their open days or
to their interview days.
Having a chat, seeing if it fits
with you or if it doesn't, and
just sort of doing that trial and Stanford
supported me a lot in that process and
really establishing those
individual contacts.
To the people that I wanted
to the industries and
the jobs that I thought
could be interesting for me.
And sort of going through that process
throughout the two years until I found my
way and the place where I wanted to be and
where I'm actually now for
the last nine years almost now.
So it was a pretty nice fit in the end but
I said a very tailored approach,
this is what I liked,
and they valued a lot.
It was not about what I should do or
what I was supposed to do.
But what I wanted to do me myself
as Patricia and this is a for
me was a very, very, very valued
the support that I got from Stanford.
>> And Sita.
>> Yeah, I don't know if my videos still
working I you guys are all frozen for
me but I'll just keep talking.
[LAUGH] So yeah, I very similar and
still different to
Patricia I would say
also very entrepreneurial
approach very many different
paths that I used.
I actually started using
the network before the GSB.
I encourage all of you guys to think
about the time that you also still have
before you start your MBA.
I Happen to be in Berlin when some
alum called me to congratulate me
on getting an offer from the GSB and
I ended up actually doing
an internship with his company before
I actually moved to California.
So that was interesting.
I definitely also did
the internship thing.
I actually did two internships in my
MBA summer, which is kind of unusual.
I did one in San Francisco
at a startup and
one in consulting in Europe to
sort of keep my options open
to get an offer to return to
that sort of safety thing.
Was kind of nice to know that
there is also the sort of more
consulting and
corporate paths that you can follow.
I did do a class research
sort of projects and
I also did a lot of alum reach outs and
then actually took the spring
break to go to London,
which was my sort of destination,
I was looking for.
So all of these things and
in the end the job that I actually
ended up taking came from
a sort of different US Schools.
Mailing lists were sort of the different
marketing clubs were sending each other
opportunities that obviously,
I wouldn't have gotten if I
wasn't at one of those schools.
And yeah, just hit it off with
the people at the company, yeah,
any anything, any of those
different things could have worked.
Yeah, great, definitely encourage you
to look at the time before your MBA.
[LAUGH]
>> Good advice.
This next question All direct
to Christina and Stefan.
How do you think the Stanford MBA
differentiates you and the European
marketplace or maybe just even changes
your approach to how you solve problems or
see opportunities?
Christina maybe starting with you?
>> Yeah, sure, so I work at the lever and
joined like four months ago,
six months ago.
And one thing that I noticed as soon as
I started obviously meeting people was
that there's a big share of leadership
that actually has a Stanford MBA.
And obviously ,some are more
senior alumni than others,
but it was pretty sort
of like interesting for
me to notice how coming from the US were
like, it's so easy to find a stem from.
Yeah, I landed on this company and
then there they were and and
even when I was looking at other options
then that he or was always through
Stanford alumni who ended up also having
a lot of leadership positions there.
So I think that obviously sort of
was encouraging as I was looking for
new opportunities in Europe.
And then in terms of how different
serve maybe differentiates you,
but how does a Stanford MBA shaped the way
you think about your job or issues.
I think something that I retained
from a lot of their classes that
I took was going back to your aspiration
of what leader you want to be.
And so a lot of the decisions that I
take in my day to day, whether it's
with restaurant partners, people working
at the labor group, or my own employees.
It's really trying to go back to
the set of principles that I think
Stanford really helped me tease
out over those two years.
And, Stefan, how do you think
the Stanford MBA differentiates you or
how you approach things?
>> I think there's two elements.
I think there's the kind of like,
general interest from people
in Europe in Silicon Valley.
And I think Maxim mentioned earlier
right that Stanford is kind of like at
the epicenter of it.
So that's a given but that does make
you a, I don't want to say a desirable
person but I mean I have a lot of
meetings but people are super curious
about Silicon Valley and
like different approaches to things.
And it's a very good starting point if
you're trying to connect with somebody
that you might not otherwise be able to
get in touch with or something like that,
that kind of like general hi,
let's talk about Silicon Valley and
what I learned there and what I saw there.
Is always a really,
really good starting point and
it's something that people
are genuinely interested in.
The other thing to me is I think
it's more of a personal thing.
I was always under the impression before
the NBA that I could learn hard skills.
Through like many different avenues and
I really focus on soft skill
development at Stanford.
I think Stanford itself pushes
you in that direction a lot.
But that was super important to me and
I think that's a very big differentiating
factor from what I can tell to
other MBA programs as well.
And again,
obviously didn't attend those but
just from talking to a lot of alumni
I certainly have a very different
approach to kind of like leadership
as Christina mentioned just now
it's like a very kind of like let's
get in behind a shared vision.
Let's do it together.
I think I'm much more aware of how I come
across to others than I was in the past.
I never really thought about it,
because nobody ever told me that I should,
[LAUGH] quite frankly.
And there's a lot of like things and
kind of like also this Silicon Valley
approach of that it's okay to fail,
that we've definitely implemented in our
company, and we're not worried about it.
And I think it might be different in
other European countries, but in Germany,
there's certainly a stigma,
a very negative stigma around failure.
And we've made it completely okay
obviously under the right circumstances.
And that's helped us tremendously,
we've been able to achieve
things that I don't think we
would have with another culture.
>> Okay,
the next question I'll pose to Sita and
Christina, any favorite to GSB courses or
experiences or
resources that you continue
to leverage today?
Sita, maybe we'll start with you.
>> Yeah,
I'm very diverse set of classes that
it's always the classes that you don't.
You can never know which ones will
be it will come in handy 10 years
after the fact that's the weird one.
The ones that were sort of obvious
to me because that was my reason to,
one of the big things for me is was the
shift to renewables and climate change.
So took a lot of energy
classes across the street.
So in the Stanford University
not the business school.
That's obviously been a huge
helping factor in just being
knowledgeable about the space
that I want to enter.
Also helped me understand that I
personally wasn't going to be coming in as
a business undergrad.
I personally wasn't going to become
an engineer or a master's in engineering,
but I got enough knowledge out of it to
know that I had a place in that world.
And I could sort of toss to the topics,
other GSB classes that really stuck
with me were around HR and leadership.
And not so much the sort of the ones
that I knew were going to be great that
everybody talks about, but also the ones
that are a little bit more tangible and
hands on there was something I don't know
the colloquial term was hiring and firing.
Really hands on class that
I think about every single
time I have sort of
managerial topic coming up.
Acting with power [LAUGH] was a surprising
one that really helped me come out
of my shell and
then try a different leadership style.
That I think about a lot.
And weirdly a statistics
class that I also end up and
every time somebody comes to me
with some sort of fact or stat or
I read an article in the news,
I question it in a very different
way than I used to
>> Christina happen you have any favorite
GSB courses or experiences that
you continue to leverage today?
>> Yeah, so
when I was a GSB I took two sales classes.
Because if there was one thing that was
felt very uncomfortable was negotiations.
And I had this almost
like chip on my shoulder.
So I went I did the took the two classes,
and after that, I was like,
you know this was great.
I'll never get there into like
a sales role and here yeah,
I'm like global commercial delivery room.
And it's funny because,
I go back to those classes every day,
as in beyond the tools
that you could think well,
maybe I can get them in there's
plenty of sales classes and so on.
It was morelike the approach in which
those tools were offered to us and
so a lot of live sort of like cases and
simulations.
And then similarly, I took classes
like managing difficult conversations,
managing growing enterprises where again,
it's like you prepare a case.
You're called out and
you have to basically act pretty much and
be riding in on the moment.
And in the role that I have seen
a negotiation table with counterparts,
lawyers and
it's like everything is in the moment.
I've gotten so much back to it.
I've written back to professors telling
them about something that had happened and
what was their perspective.
So definitely helpful probably
in the most unexpected
way because I didn't think
I was going to get a role
similar to those classes but
yeah, it's been great.
>> This next question I'll have Maxime
start with that anyone else who wants to
chime in is more than welcome to.
What advice would you give to
someone who would like to go
to Europe directly after
the Stanford GSB?.
>> I think Sita covered
that a little bit already.
It also worked out in
my station thinks if I
mentioned about networking braille to GSB.
So basically if you can see the such
an option to come back to Europe and
your home country anywhere in the world,
it's worth talking
to people before GSB during summer breaks,
winter breaks.
And just staying in touch
with people helps a lot.
Just understand what's
going on their side,
both like within your friend's community,
your previous employers,
just being in the loop and
understand what's going on helps a lot.
And besides that I'm not sure how
it works out in other countries.
In Moscow, it was really a close
community of applicants applying for
the major US Graduate School
of Businesses, MBA programs.
And we actually got friends and I've got
a lot of friends during that period.
We just applied together to
different universities and
I got admitted to Stanford, somebody told
me to two other great universities and
we came back and
we our kids are friends now.
And it's just fun,
just talking to the people who
share the same ideas and
have the same backgrounds.
And also I also did
the store among different
business schools prior to my application.
And if you have the Russian
guys who studied at Harvard,
Wharton and Chicago at that time,
who at Stanford University.
Who were like one-two years
prior to my graduation.
They also became friends of mine since
that week, so there was one piece
of advice just network a lot within
this community prayer enduring justice.
And the second one, I personally believe
that Stanford has great resources.
Although, I truly at this 15 years ago,
it was the case that I relied more on
myself rather than on official venues.
If I would love to work back
in the home country in Russia.
And I definitely decided
that I graduated first, and
then come back, and then start looking for
a job rather than trying to do
both like partying during the day.
Working during the night,
trying to find the job you're in like
summer/winter trying to find
a job during morning hours.
It doesn't work out.
So I prefer just to focus more
on understanding the classes and
learning some something talking and
parting with my friends during GSBs.
And then I graduated, come back and
then I started actually looking for
a new job like.
Anyone else have advice, Christina, yeah?
Yeah, I can jump in.
So I actually did look into
moving to Europe right after GSB.
And so I took through the summer
in between the two years
the opportunity to come to London for
a week.
Obviously, I've done sort of like a bit
of prep work up front a bit maybe
what industries.
And it was very bad way,
it's not that I had very clear it has
to be consumer or attack like I was
very sort of wide spectrum of
things that I saw myself doing.
because also that's what you do an MBA for
sort of and they're sending that up.
So my advice would be start early and
do not [INAUDIBLE] the schedule
is busy at the GSB.
But there's always that one week and
you don't even have to be in the place,
but just allocate time early enough.
And I did keep in touch with the alumni
that I had pinged during that summer,
because I think one thing to remember
is that, alumni are people and
they're very nice people and
they like to stay in touch.
You're not just simply asking them for
a job, you're making a human connection.
So I found that a lot of alumni
have stayed in touch with.
And then I actually quote and
quote, use them leverage them as
I was deciding what I wanted
to go back immediately or not.
In sort of understanding,
what was best for me and so
I ended up taking a job in the US,
I didn't move straight after.
But when I then was back in London,
it took me two weeks to find a new job and
I had like plenty of opportunities.
So it was very much, yeah,
I guess, I would say start early.
You don't have to go to them and
say you're 100% sure,
you're going to move to Europe,
be transparent.
People are not expecting you to take
any decision during your first year and
so that gives you a lot of freedom.
I think I'm in shaping a bit
your career after GSB.
Great, thank you.
Well, many of your responses have
addressed some of the questions that we
have from our audience.
But I want to specifically dive into
some of those now that are open for
anyone to answer.
We have a question here
of it's sort of twofold.
What was the most unexpected or impactful
experience during your time at Stanford,
and maybe what was one of
the more challenging experiences?
So who would like to tackle one of those?
I can say in terms of unexpected.
If somebody then wants to take the next
one, there's touchy feeling as a class,
which everybody in which
Stanford is very famous for.
And there are a lot of people
who go to Stanford and
who are just 100% sure they
will participate in that class.
And that's one of the big events
of their Stanford program.
I was not on that line of thinking,
I was more on the line of thinking work
with everybody does it, I will not.
So I didn't take it
until the end actually,
when I had a little bit of fear of
missing out in the last semester and
I registered just in case, there was
something important happening there.
And although I resisted through the first
classes where I was still trying to get
convinced about the idea.
I have to say for me,
and very surprisingly,
it was one of the best experiences
I've done, not only at Stanford but
also I would say beyond Stanford.
The level of human connection.
So it's not really about content,
it's really about relationship.
The level of human connection that
we experienced during that class and
the conversations we could or we manage
to have on a person to person basis.
Tying to understand what Stephen
was saying how you come across and
how others view you, which you may
not have considered until now,
because you'll never
just thought about it.
This I found the most I have to say after
the two years the most powerful and
unexpected event for me, at least from my
the many classes that I took at the GSB.
The other unexpected surprises or
impactful experiences
folks want to highlight?
I think I've got three unexpected
surprises that I would
probably share with you.
First, I didn't expect, such a beautiful
nature around the Stanford University and
just going out in the woods,
and data lake, and
the mountains and
ocean in the close proximity.
With that definitely made difference for
me and for my family.
And the second one, I will say that
I came with the son of mine too and
my spouse to the campus, and
I didn't expect kindergartens and
schools of such high quality of care.
I definitely recommend for
those who would come with families
to consider that option on
the Stanford campus person.
And there are so many things happening and
we were told when they came on the first
day that it is really important for
us to build this skill how to
manage our schedule, right?
Both including sleeping and
network, and so many clubs, so
many classes, so
many great people you want to talk to.
It's like drinking from a firehose,
I would say, and
it's definitely one of the first abilities
I had to manage in order to survive.
Basically, I didn't expect that, but
it helped a lot after graduation as well.
[LAUGH] I can quickly jump in.
Before the GSB,
my life was pretty straight lined, right,
I did like economics undergrad,
I had a company and things like this.
And so in terms of unexpected
impactful things, I was very hesitant
to take kind of strange classes that
didn't just check off my boxes off.
This has a one on one correlation
to make me a better or
whatever manager leader or
something like this.
The best class in my opinion was
a mindfulness class that I took.
I don't even know what department,
it wasn't the GSB,
I went in there on the advice of my
wife who said you should really do this.
And I said, okay, when will I
ever do this other than now and
Sita knows me well,
that's what she's laughing and I loved it.
And if there's one piece of advice and
I don't know if this is my
place to give you advice now.
But I would drop your expectations and
not just focus on the things
that you think have a one on one
correlation to making you more successful,
whatever your goal is richer and
more powerful.
Take those two years and literally
pump the brakes for just one second,
read the whatever 100 electives,
especially in the second year
that you can take, and just take some
crazy ones that just interest you.
And what's the worst thing
that can happen to you?
You go to two classes, and
then you just like don't go for
the rest of the semester, and I wish
I would have done a lot more of that.
And in terms of the challenge,
that is kind of also the challenge, right?
Because once you start doing that,
there aren't going to be two classes
that you're kind of interested in.
There's going to be 25 and
it's 25 a semester.
So you have to just be okay
with saying look, I'd love to,
I'm kind of interested in these 25.
But I can only do two because otherwise,
my schedule is so
crazy that I'm missing out
on a million other things.
>> Any other challenging experiences
during your time at Stanford?
>> I think the challenges
are always not being dragged by
what a lot of people do or
I think what we were just talking about,
sort of what you think is going to be
good for you, and for your career.
And sort of staying grounded
while you're trying to achieve,
and that also becomes sometimes
very confused and foggy.
And so at the time I felt that I
was almost sort of getting lost and
not getting the most out of it.
And then now, a couple of years out,
I actually realized that that's actually
the process you're meant to go through.
You don't go to the GSB
because you have it all clear.
If anything is an opportunity to
admit that not everything is clear,
also life doesn't go
always as you planned it.
So there's that element and that becomes
even more true as you graduate and
life moves on for
a lot of your classmates.
And so I think the challenge in the moment
is always sort of being mindful of
that and
not getting scared of not starting
doubting yourself that maybe you're
not doing enough or too much.
They always say you can either sleep and
not go to the party, or
finish your assignments, and
get a good grade, or go to class.
It's just there's too much to do
that sometimes it gets overwhelming.
>> This next question,
maybe Sita, we'll have you start.
And Stefan, you might have a perspective
here having spent, I think
you said 17 years in the US, but we're
seeing some questions from panelists.
If you are not originally a European
citizen or if you're coming from
another part of the world and want to
transition to Europe, is that possible?
And maybe you can even reflect all of you
on your peers, and your colleagues, and
your classmates in your
various home countries.
Do you see non-European
citizens who are now currently
working in Europe who are GSB grads?
And Sita I called on you because
of your personal connection there.
>> Yeah, [LAUGH] yeah, I'm happy to share.
So this was my unexpected.
I didn't want to put it in
the challenge or unexpected thing, but
I met my husband at
the GSB who's an American.
I thought I wanted to come
back to Europe after the GSB,
met this American guy unexpected,
not what I had planned.
Yeah, the way he did it was he had
worked in the summer internship.
He worked for
a then USS startup in product and
they were just in the process
of expanding to Europe.
And he basically got an offer from them
for the Silicon Valley office, but
then managed to transfer that over to
the UK, so they were sponsoring him.
So that's one of the paths
that I know pretty well.
Obviously, we've since gotten married, so
that's another thing that is sometimes
possible and sometimes, obviously not.
The other thing that he also did, so
I mentioned that I had an offer from
a consulting firm that I had worked with.
And so we tried Amsterdam over
the summer by the way and
then decided we wanted to move to London.
So that was another little thing there.
Obviously try whatever you can, but
consulting obviously has global
recruiting and they obviously know
how to do all of the visa things.
So that's a fairly safe one I would say.
You can even do an internship in one city,
get an offer,
transfer that offer or apply directly
with the office that you want to go to.
So that's how I went to Amsterdam and
we would have been able to go
to London with that as well.
Other friends, yeah,
unfortunately I'm aware of a few of
our classmates who stayed in the US,
but didn't,
in the former presidents era,
didn't manage to quite stay longer.
Some of them have come to Europe, I don't
know exactly the visa situation, but
it seemed to be significantly easier
obviously than staying in the US at
the time.
I think hopefully that'll
loosen up [LAUGH] my future,
but those are the things
I can think of right now.
>> And to just add like one or
two more things.
I mean, apart from immigration things,
right, which I don't know anything
about how difficult that is.
But I think like Sita said,
for sure big companies, right,
are always a good starting point.
And I can just talk for
little Munich as my wife calls it.
She's from New York, so
it's very little to her.
But even there, right, there's plenty of
English speaking opportunities as well.
So that's clearly not an issue in London
or any of the other bigger cities, but so
even the language thing, I think because
that's a big one for a lot of people.
You can do without, I mean, my wife did
not speak a word of German when we moved
and she's now speak some, but I don't
think that should be a huge concern.
But I would come back to the alumni,
right, as the first starting point.
I mean, there's plenty of
alumni in whatever important
powerful positions in
virtually every big cities.
So if there's a larger city that you're
interested in or a company you're
interested in, right, with somebody from
another office, I would start there.
And I'm sure if you If you're serious
about wanting to move to Europe, there's
opportunities that the Stanford network
can help identify together with you.
And you can then make the move.
I mean, we have several just coming
back to this tribe that Sita was talking
about earlier, our little ten
person group here in Europe.
There are several Americans on
it that moved to Europe and
are now still here and part of our group.
So it's definitely a longer term
alternative also for people.
Okay, we have a question here
from an audience member.
Obviously, there are a number of wonderful
European business schools as well.
I don't know if any of you are considering
those, but what are the things that you
felt you could only learn doing your MBA
in the US or maybe the GSB in particular?
[CROSSTALK] I'm sorry, go ahead.
Go, go, go.
Okay, I'll quickly do mine.
This was the reason for
me to decide to go to Stanford because
I visited a couple different schools.
And the one thing for
me is that at Stanford,
you have the protagonist of the case
sitting there in front of you and
telling you the story and
all of the back story behind it.
I can read a case at home,
I can think about what I would do, and
I could maybe discuss it
with some smart people.
But hearing from the founder or something
about the struggle they were facing and
what really went on behind the scenes,
the things that they maybe didn't
necessarily put in the case.
That's the kind of learning where I
thought I can only get that here.
This is Silicon Valley,
a lot of the alums are still around.
That just blew my mind.
I think [INAUDIBLE] other than that,
sorry, [INAUDIBLE] but
like I took a class in which they invited.
So there were two cofounders that
started a company then they separated,
not in sort of great terms.
And the professor invites both
of them in two different days.
And you hear both [INAUDIBLE],
which it almost gets uncomfortable for
the class we hear, right?
because it's like you hear one and
then you feel you're on their side, and
then you go and
you hear the other one of them.
It's just like I think I agree.
I mean, it's one of the elements
that made me pick Stanford.
The other one for me was I wanted to get
a bit of the Silicon Valley experience,
which in reality for
me meant do something that I'd never done.
I started a shoe company
while at Stanford.
And my family's absolutely
not entrepreneurial,
so for me it was going way
out of my comfort zone.
And then in Silicon Valley there were
all these people so excited about me and
my business.
But yeah,
the case was definitely one of the big,
big things for
me that made me pick Stanford.
Patricia.
So the MBA is either one year or two year
program, so it's quite the long time.
And I felt it was a long time
to not work actually, and
not make a professional career.
So I wanted to make the best out of it.
And for me, going to the west,
especially going to Stanford and
Silicon Valley also meant
the cultural experience.
So it's one thing to get the class and to
understand your statistical concepts and
even the case and discuss it.
But it's another thing to experience
how life is in Silicon Valley,
how people think, how people behave.
I mean, there's a lot of different
elements that are subjective
that you don't really measure,
are not written on paper.
I would not have gotten it if I
would not have gone to Stanford.
And for me, that was the one of the key
elements in taking the decision to really
have this comprehensive experience.
So not only classes,
but going beyond that.
Great, thank you.
Well, I do want to be mindful of
the time as I know we're coming up on
our end point here.
Again, you'll see another
poll pop up momentarily and
we'd love to get your input there.
I want to absolutely thank all of our
panelists for sharing your experiences
today, both about your time at the GSB, as
well as your time now currently in Europe.
I think it was very, very helpful
to hear about that transition and
how you made that transition.
For all of our attendees today,
we hope that this is just the start
of your Stanford MBA journey.
And a wonderful way to continue that
journey is through a site called
MyStanford.mba.
Please check this out
if you haven't already.
There's an opportunity to create your
own personalized dashboard there.
It will tee up clubs and
courses that might be of interest to you,
student or alumni profiles
that might resonate with you.
If you start an application you can
track your application progress there.
And it'll also suggest other events
that might be of interest to you,
such as the one today.
So again, thank you to our panelists.
Thank you to all of our attendees.
I hope you've enjoyed today's session.
And best of luck in your MBA journey.
[MUSIC]